[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute zeige ich euch wie ich eine
geburtstagstorte für ein einjähriges
mädchen mache und zwar wird die tochter
meiner freundin die sänger ein jahr
ich weiß ihr wünscht euch auch mal
torten für jungs auch ich muss echt
sagen meine freundin und ich kriegen
alle irgendwie nur mädchen also egal was
in den letzten jahren hat die welt gab
es waren immer nur mädchen daher immer
mädchen torten ich würde mir auch
wünschen dass man ein kleiner junge
dabei ist aber eine jungen torte werde
ich mit sicherheit auch manchmal machen
falls ja so war es einfach ein anlass
dafür gibt oder er sagt einfach dass es
so dringend dann schreibt mir gerne ein
paar themen in die kommentare dann mache
ich das wirklich super gerne ich habe
ich eine zweistöckige torte und ich mein
mädchen sind eben auch kleine
prinzessinnen daher eine prinzessinnen
torte und dies wirklich ganz einfach in
der herstellung ich finde sie sieht auch
sehr edel und klassisch aus aber
trotzdem so ein bisschen kindlich ich
starte jetzt direkt mit den teigen die
habe ich bereits gestern gemacht also
insgesamt zwei tage für die torte immer
so ein paar stunden und dann ist es
wirklich super vorbereitet als teig
nehme ich meinen basic teig den mandeln
rührteig habe ihn mit zitronenschale
verfeinert und ich gebe noch ein
bisschen bittermandel aroma mit rein
das hebt den wandel geschmack richtig
gut ihr könnte alternativ amaretto
nehmen aber amateur ist mit alk und
daher nehme ich hier die alkoholfreie
variante und ich habe jetzt einmal die
große menge gemacht und habe sie in 220
cm ringen gebacken
ich habe einfach den teig aufgeteilt
damit gleichmäßig schön aufgeht und ich
später eine hohe torte bekomme und hier
habe ich die kleine menge und die
bereitet jetzt im bug rahmen zu und
werden später tortenböden ausschneiden
beziehungsweise ausstechen
[Musik]
und die sind einfach hier einfüllen und
das mache ich jetzt so weil ich keinen
kleineren trotten ring habe und die
torte ringe lassen sich ja bis 18
zentimeter größe einstellen und ich
mache aber oben eine kleinere torte und
das ist echt die beste variante also
jetzt einfach alle kuchen gebacken schön
abkühlen lassen und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich mich schon mal um die marmelade
und um die decke kümmern und vor dem
backen ziehe ich den teig immer gerne am
rand hoch so packte gleichmäßiger die
marmelade verwende ich 800 gramm
heidelbeeren entweder frisch oder
tiefgefroren 100 gramm gelierzucker da
hab ich den 321 zucker 2 limetten und
fünf gramm arriaga defizit tiefgefrorene
heidelberg
die gebe ich in einen topf da kommt der
gelierzucker dazu und ich nehme jetzt
auch wirklich nur ganz wenig zucker
damit die masse nicht wie marmelade süß
wird sondern er sei ja nicht bleibt das
gleiche dann die torte richtig schön aus
dann den limetten abrieb und da müsste
einfach drauf achten dass die
limettenschale verzehrbar ist dann noch
den saft zu pressen
und jetzt einfach den topf auf mittel
hohe hitze stellen und das ganze so ein
bisschen köcheln lassen direkt mit dem
ak gaga sorgt dann dafür dass es etwas
festwirt und ich lasse es dann schön
einkaufen
[Musik]
die masse kocht jetzt gleich und da ist
immer mehr flüssigkeit enthalten als man
denkt und ich lasse jetzt auf kochen
machen den spritzschutz drauf denn die
haben wirklich eine richtig tolle aber
sehr intensive farbe und dann las ich
die masse peter fünf minuten einkochen
größe ab und zu mal durch damit nichts
am topfboden kleben bleibt schatz auch
auf mittlerer stufe dann runter und dann
dürfte sie fertig sein
[Musik]
da freue ich mich jetzt an die deko
mache mache ich gerade auch die
buttercreme ich habe die bereits
vorbereitet und zwar mache ich die
swissmedic weiter creme und da gibt es
auch bereits das grundrezept auf meinem
kanal und da mich jetzt einfach eiweiß
und die butter zusammen
das ganze wurde erhitzt damit ich
einfach kein rohes ei weiß habe und
schaut mal richtig schön fest und stabil
der arbeit nicht zu vergessen die creme
ist auch von dann tauglich und ich habe
sie bisher jetzt aromatisiert mit
vanille extrakt jetzt mache ich aber
noch ein bisschen lärm gehört rein das
habe ich noch übrig hatte ich nämlich
gemacht einfach ein paar esslöffel
[Musik]
ganz färben nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen
was von der marmelade und 70 damit sie
einfach keine stückchen habe dann nehme
ich einfach die natürliche fahrer aus
dem blau werben
eine schöne rosa farbe leicht lila
einmal kurz abschmecken und da kann ich
entweder noch ein bisschen zitronen köln
gehört einfügen oder ein bisschen moment
blaubeeren voll lecker genau so las ich
sie und die butter kleben lag ich jetzt
kurz hier bei raumtemperatur benutze ich
ja gleich aber vorher mache ich jetzt
schon mal die deko die krone und dem
zauberstab die deko nehme ich jetzt
etwas blüten passte die trocknet nämlich
super schnell aus und dann kann die
krone gut aus herten nämlich jetzt weiße
blüten passte die kann man natürlich
auch einfärben ich würde sie aber danach
erst färben
das habe ich so schön weich geknetet und
rollten aus und damit die krone
gleichmäßig dick wird oder dünn wird
nehme ich jetzt hier meine aus rahlstedt
3 mm und rollt es jetzt schön aus
das habe ich das hier schon ausgerollt
und dann nehmt ihr einfach ein stück
papier als schablone und ich habe das
jetzt bereits ausgerechnet bzw
ausgemessen
ich nehme zu so einem kleinen der serie
habe das papier drum herum gestellt und
es schließt genau bündig ab so groß wird
die krone bzw so klein es kommt ja auch
die obere torte die höhe finde ich auch
gut
und dann einfach halbieren und ich habe
es dann nochmal gedrittelt und jetzt
kann ich hier oben einfach die spitze
wegschneiden
[Musik]
guck ich mal ob mir die form gefällt
perfekt die spitzen werde ich oben dann
noch ein bisschen stumpfer machen aber
so ist schon mal gut
jetzt könnt ihr entweder die schablone
benutzen und direkt ausschneiden oder
ihr strukturiert das ganze vorher
ich hab hier so'n struktur roller da
kann man das noch schön als zusatz
machen
[Musik]
und dann mit einem stumpfen messer auf
der silikon matte mit der schablone
ausschneiden
dann bespricht den bisheringen mit etwas
backt raumspray damit es hier auch dran
haftet kann es drum herum legen dann
hier am ende mit s-bahn kleber einfach
zusammenkleben jetzt mache ich noch
einen schönen zauberstab dafür nehme ich
wieder blüten passte das nämlich jetzt
für die komplette deko die eben schön
aushärten muss die rolle ich jetzt einen
zentimeter dick auf
dann wieder strukturieren aber es darf
ruhig ein bisschen dicker bleiben zu 5
mm in etwa jetzt nehme ich einfach einen
schönen stern ausstecher
und hier kommt dann der schlick spies
rein damit man den zauberstab auch
wirklich schön festmachen kann mit etwas
essbarem kleber kurz antrocknen lassen
und jetzt kann ich die zahl eins noch
machen dafür die blüten passte weich
formen und weich kneten und dann zu
einer langen rolle formen
[Musik]
da zeichne ich mir jetzt auch eine
schablone ich nenne ich mal die krone
die einzelnen bisschen größer sein als
die krone jetzt für mich ein ende
lang und spitz oder halt so ein bisschen
dünner zu und viele jetzt ein bisschen
butterbrotpapier drauf damit ich einfach
mit dem bleistift nicht in kontakt komme
etwas faktoren spray zum befestigen und
dann einfach mit dieser langen rolle
die zahl 1 hinlegen oder auch eine
andere zahl unten schneidet immer gerne
gerade weg da hatte ich einen guten
stand habe und jetzt gebe ich der zahl 1
einfach noch einen fuß fuhr nach links
und rechts sieht immer ganz hübsch aus
der berührung stelle kommt jetzt wieder
etwas essbar kleber trend dann ankleben
und auch hier unten einen
schaschlikspieß reinstecken mit einem
flachen starb mache ich dann immer schön
gerade damit auch auf der torte gerade
auflegt an die verbindungsstelle kommt
dann immer etwas essbarer kleber unten
dann noch einen schaschlikspieß rein
so hat die zahl eins auch halt auf der
torte
[Musik]
und dann ablegen und auch trocknen
lassen
die tortenböden sind schön kalt ich
hatte sie auch kurz im kühlschrank
ihr könnt sie auch kurz in den
gefrierschrank stellen nach dem abkühlen
dann kann man sie nämlich super gut
schneiden ich schneide sie jetzt jeweils
zwei mal durch
nämlich meine torten dreh platte unter
lege ich immer gern so ein silikon per
drauf und dann die gamaschen boards ein
genau dort drauf dann den ersten
tortenboden das caching wort hilft mir
dabei die torte später richtig schön
gerade und fleisch zu streichen
nehme ich meine buttercreme und füllen
sie in einen spritzbeutel 1
jetzt zeige ich euch wie die torte fülle
und zwar nehme ich jetzt immer ein
bisschen buttercreme erst mal an den
rand
da noch ein bisschen was unten rein das
sind der mitte streiche ich jetzt ganz
schön flach da kommt nämlich die frucht
reif da ein bisschen frucht einfüllen
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt der zweite boden drauf
und so fühle ich jetzt die gesamte torte
ich werde aber jetzt einen tortenring
drumherum setzen so wie sie immer schön
gerade und einfach auch etwas stabiler
aber so konnte tier zumindest immer
direkt sehen wie ich erfülle
[Musik]
und ich muss hier im prinzip nur
aufpassen dass die fruchtige einlage
also diese heidelberg nicht an den rand
gelangen
[Musik]
und ganz oben drauf setzt sich immer den
tortenboden und so kann ich dann die
torte mit einem torten retter abdecken
und im kühlschrank kühlen und fülle in
der zwischenzeit noch die kleine torte
und da nehme ich wie gesagt einfach
einen ausstieg zu einem großen und werde
die torte dann eben genau so zusammen
schichten
[Musik]
die torte muss ich jetzt praktisch nach
augenmaß gerade machen denn sollen
kleinen porträt habe ich nicht jetzt
kommt ihr auch in den kühlschrank bis so
richtig schön fest wird für mindestens
ein bis zwei stunden den restlichen
kuchenteig die restliche marmelade und
die restliche buttercreme werde ich
jetzt einfach verkneten und kleine
bällchen daraus formen mache ich immer
ganz gerne ist immer eine richtig tolle
resteverwertung und wenn ein bisschen
creme fehlen sollte kann man das ganze
immer mit frischkäse quark oder sahne
einfach ausfüllen dann gibt es immer
noch kleine bisher welchen dazu
der kuchen ist jetzt gut durchgeführt
jetzt kann ich ihnen aus der form
herauslösen mit einem tortenring messer
ich könnte hier auch gerne etwas
backpapier vorher in den ring legen
bevor die torte geschichte wird so geht
es natürlich auch schweizer marsch wenn
ich die torte mit der schule lege ich
gerne backpapier rein weil die garage
einfach so fest wird im kühlschrank dass
es anschließend echt schwierig wird aber
buttercreme geht es echt auch so
habe ich eine kleine lücke rein gemacht
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
ihr könnt jetzt entweder noch mal
buttercreme zubereiten und damit die
torte glattstreichen die ist ja von dann
tauglich oder nimmt garage und weil bei
mir einfach die torte noch zwei tage
halten muss und die danach richtig schön
fest wird und vor allem schnell nehme
ich jetzt weiß ich es läge jetzt hier
das zweite geschenk obendrauf
so habe ich hier den perfekten abschluss
und kann jetzt die zwischenräume einfach
mit der gage film erst einmal eine erste
schicht um die krümel hier zu binden und
alles abzudichten
und danach kommt noch die zweite glatte
schicht drauf das war jetzt die erste
schicht jetzt kommt in den kühlschrank
bis die schicht festwirt und danach
kommt die zweite die gleitschicht drauf
anschließend dann das k-wort unternehmen
und die oberfläche auftreten und nach
dem kompletten glatt streichen werde ich
die torte noch mal kühl
etwa eine halbe stunde bis sie schön
fest ist und da kommt schon die von der
decke drauf
und für so kleine wirken wie hier oder
hier mache ich die garage immer ein
bisschen warm ist dass er wieder
flüssiger wird da kann ich ganz kleine
macken nämlich schön ausgleichen ohne
dabei die komplette garage auf der torte
zu verletzen
so finde ich die torten jetzt richtig
gut und jetzt kommen sie in den
kühlschrank damit sie richtig gut durch
kühlen bevor die fahrbahndecke darüber
kommt
mittlerweile sind auch die figuren aus
blüten passt jetzt endlich getrocknet
und ich habe sie bereits ausgelöst
jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder bemalen
oder besprühen mit lebensmittelfarbe ich
nehme jetzt hier dieses metallic spray
in pink und einmal in gold die gründung
wird jetzt bei mir pink das stellen auch
und die einzel gold
bei den sprühflaschen ist immer ganz
wichtig haltet sie senkrecht also lieber
dann das zu färbende objekt bewegen wenn
ihr nämlich so macht entweicht das gas
und die farbe bleibt in der flasche das
wäre echt schade
und jetzt einfach schön trocknen lassen
am besten alles über nacht und dann kann
ich morgen die torte mit von damit über
zieht und fertig dekorieren die große
torte kann ich jetzt schon mal auf
meinen kickboard setzen das wird auch
das präsentations port für die torte und
zwar muss ich jetzt einen flipper machen
also zuerst einmal die torte umdrehen
das geht natürlich nur wenn sie richtig
kalt ist
dann her dass garching bord lösen ein
bisschen genauer streichen aber nur
hauchdünn und aufpassen dass die torte
jetzt nicht durch die garage führt und
jetzt das wort draufsetzen schnell
umdrehen und nochmal mitteschön
ausrichten
jetzt fange ich direkt damit an die
torte von dort zu überziehen
und die habe ich jetzt ein kilo weißen
fondant bereits weich geknetet dann
nehme ich immer gerne so ein bisschen
kokosfett für die hände dann schön
geschmeidig kneten und auf etwas becker
stärke ausrollen becker stärke ist eine
stärke die nicht klappt und man kann sie
später einfach wieder weg bruder
so jetzt auch da zum helfen gerd kuck
mal
jetzt habe ich hier die torte und die
garage ist das schön fest und auch schön
trocken jetzt darfst du die torte
besprühen mit back grands prix wartet
man die flasche immer so halten so und
sprühen genau
verstreicht mal so ein bisschen so
eigentlich geht es auch mit den händen
aber ich weiß nicht ob sie gewaschen
sind deswegen liefert der film so thema
und nicht regie okay ich bin deine
assistentin schön da oben noch bisschen
da ist noch trocken
guck mal hier sagt du kannst das gut
ok jetzt muss ich den fondant drauflegen
das mache ich kurz und dann den fondant
trüber legen
das wird kein weißer brachen ein
das wird für senna für das baby eine
geburtstagstorte ja von jabba mit
schneide ich hier den überrest erst mal
weg kannst du das tor wieder zusammen
kneten hier das benutzen wir gleich für
die kleine torte auf okay das ist jetzt
dein fondant stück ok damit darfst du
dann was machen ich nehme dann lieber
mit den fotos hier den rand schön
wegschneiden das geht am besten mit
einem marzipan messer weil es einfach
schön stimmt ist und jetzt nehme ich
einen kleinen blätter und kann jetzt
hier die ganze schön nach unten
streichen so wird richtig schön gerade
die torte umdrehen oktober müsste im
prinzip nur darauf achten dass euch die
torte nicht aus der hand rutscht mir ist
es noch nicht passiert aber fast fast
und einmal war die torte nicht genug
gekühlt dann wird sie natürlich
zerquetscht also philipp over wirklich
immer nur dann machen wenn die torte gut
gefüllt ist und wenn ihr sie gut in der
hand habt guck mal und wenn ihr so eine
kleine mark gehabt wie hier vorne dann
bekommt ihr die auch ganz einfach wieder
raus
die geht jetzt auch nicht weg wenn ich
mit dem kletter darüber gebe es einfach
eingedrückt ist dann könnt ihr einfach
einen schnitt von unternehmen natürlich
dieselbe farbe und hier ein bisschen
wasser und das ganze so ein bisschen
weich machen wie eine paste und dann
nehmt ihr diese passte auf so eine
palette auf und könnte dann rein
streichen also wie beim bauern
antwort das loch zu machen
das mache ich auch gerne hier am rand
unten
ihr seht ihr hier das hier der abschluss
richtig schön ist aber da wo so kleine
lücken sind da ist es halt wirklich
dunkel da kann man es auch machen wie
man bei mir kommt jetzt hier später eine
deko drauf bei der torte weise jetzt
nicht schlimm habe ich wollte euch
einfach mal zeigen wir diese kleinen
macken weg bekommt die torte lasse jetzt
ganz kurz noch an trocknen und kann
jetzt aber schon mal meine hölzer
vorbereiten das ist ja die große torte
die kleine stelle ich oben drauf und
damit sie nicht herunter sinkt muss ich
das ganze mit dübeln ein bisschen
stabilisiert
also nehme ich jetzt erstmal ein
schaschlik spies messe hier die länge ab
mit einem lebensmittel farbstift und
kann jetzt in der länge buchen
rundhölzer zu schneiden
jetzt werden auch die richtigen
hergestellt und dafür verknetet jetzt
eins zu eins sondern und hüten passte so
entsteht modelliermasse und wenn ich
jetzt die rutsche mit von land macht
halten sie nicht weil von land einfach
nicht hart wird sondern schön
geschmeidig bleibt wenn ich sie mit
blüten passte macher trockenen sie mir
zu schnell aus also nehme ich gerne die
mischung aus beiden
ich lasse jetzt erst mal weiß und setzte
später dann besprüht jetzt kurz die
masse verkneten und richtig dünn
ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt können sie beliebige ausstecher
nehmen sie beziehen paar rosen
aussteller ihr könnt aber auch rosetten
nehmen oder auf rund ausstechen
denn es wird später sowieso noch ein
bisschen kraft also nehme ich jetzt
erstmal kleine und große und guckt
einfach wie ist gleich auf der torte
anordnen
es gibt jetzt einfach kurz hier unter
die silikon matte damit ihr nicht an
trocknen
[Musik]
ihr seht ihr es sind ja schon relativ
dünn arbeitsweisen sind dünner gemacht
mit einem ball und einer schaum matte
und hier könnt ihr einfach mit dem ball
tool am rand entlang streichen und dann
sieht man schon wie die blüten sich
schön wählen
zum trocknen lege ich sie dann hier ein
da kann man zum beispiel auch ein apfel
verpackung nehmen oder eine lehre
toffifee packung da gibt's ja auch diese
wellen oder ihr nehmt eine lehre
toffifee verpackung wobei die ein
bisschen zu klein ist oder ihr formt
einfach was aus alufolie aber es ist
doch nicht so nachhaltig und
umweltschonend
die blüten die ich weiter unten
angegeben möchte die werde ich jetzt
noch besprühen auch mit dem metallic
spray von unten nach oben sodass nach
oben hin die farbe sondern bisschen
verblasst
ich hoffe die fliegen jetzt nicht weg
durch den stau
ok ich glaube sie fliegen gleich
jetzt kann ich die an getrockneten
blüten hier auf die torte geben das
mache ich jetzt im sitzen weil es ein
bisschen dauert
dafür nehme ich jetzt essbaren kleber
dann mit einem pinsel schön auftragen an
den rand
rechts oben mit weiß anfangen und dann
eben schön der reihe nach an kleben und
nach unten hin werde ich dann dunkler
hose
blüten die klebe ich immer so
überlappend übereinander und die zweite
reihe da muss natürlich noch mal kleber
dran aber nur hier unten an den rand so
dass oben diese blüten so ein bisschen
flattern
[Musik]
für den unteren abschluss nämlich jetzt
die größten blütenblätter und halbiere
sie da streiche ich jetzt etwas kleber
an den rand und klebt ihr damit der
geraten kannte unten
als abschluss schön an die torte
[Musik]
es ist auch gefällt sie mir richtig gut
die torte kommt jetzt in den kühlschrank
da die blüten passt da auch noch mal
schön trocknen und jetzt kümmere ich
mich um die obere torte die obere torte
die wird sich jetzt auch mit weiß
von dort hatte ich jetzt ein bisschen zu
klein ausgerollt aber ich kann ihn
einfach so ein bisschen ziehen mit dem
klappt es echt super der hat nämlich
shea butter in der rezeptur und kein
palmfett und dadurch ist er eben noch
elastisch und reis nicht
[Musik]
es werden beide torten übereinander
gesetzt ich habe ich ja die holzstäbchen
einer kommt in die mitte und das ist am
sind wieso stützen für ein haus hier ist
die stütze und da kommt die zweite
stockwerk drauf ich muss immer noch ein
bisschen kürzen minimalst kürzen
die obere torte die klebe ich jetzt
einfach mit etwas garage an
ich habe ich noch mal ein bisschen
erwärmt so ist sie dann auch transport
sicher früher habe ich immer auch ganz
gerne noch einen stock also ein großes
holzstäbchen von oben nach unten in die
torte geburt aber ich muss echt sagen
die torte die kann so auch ganz sicher
transportiert werden
und ich wäre jetzt einfach die schönste
seite
für die vorderseite das ist jetzt hier
diese und mache cdu drauf und zwar den
namen dafür habe ich jetzt weiß man von
land ganz weich geknetet also wirklich
weich und da ein bisschen kokosfett
außen rum ich warum es zu einer langen
rolle und gibt diese rolle jetzt hier in
diese knet presse ist für lebensmittel
vorne habe ich schon noch töne und damit
vor mich jetzt einen langen strang
wenn dann kann man auch mit der hand
formen aber so wird es einfach schön
gleichmäßig ist hier ein bisschen becker
stärke und damit es nicht zusammenklebt
und dann einfach drehen und dann kommt
unten die kordel groß
den namen habe ich jetzt hier einmal auf
ein papier geschrieben kann ich sie
nämlich einmal hinlegen und weiß
ungefähr wie lange die strenge sein
müssen
das ende für mich immer so ein bisschen
rund damit nicht gerade abgeschnitten
aussieht
[Musik]
als kleinen tipp einfach einen zettel
hin halten
in der richtigen größe zuschneiden und
dann könnt ihr den namen optimal
drauflegen und eben dann an die torte
kleben fotos
jetzt kann ich die rückseite mit kleber
bestreichen und dann vorsichtig an der
torte an leben
[Musik]
vorsichtig andrücken und kurz antrocknen
lassen und das normale ich jetzt gleich
mit der goldfarbe dann kann man es
richtig schön hervorheben
jetzt nehme ich noch mal das goldene
metallic spray und spieß einfach in den
deckel rein und dann kann ich mit dem
pinsel jetzt hier den namen bemalen und
das muss ich jetzt im nachhinein machen
vorher geht es nicht ansonsten kommt
dann immer an die farbe dran und
verschmutzter noiret orte und das ist
jetzt so der sauberste weg
[Musik]
und dann etwas blüten pastor richtig
schön weich kneten und zu einer langen
rolle formen
ich nehme jetzt die mittlere und dann
wird es hier einfach so rein gedrückt wo
ich mit ein bisschen druck dann wird der
abschluss umso schöner
und hier nehme ich jetzt blüten passte
weil sie einfach super schnell fest wird
und auch gleich wieder gut aus der form
kommt sehe ich so ein bisschen und resi
und kann es dann raus klopfen
das wären sogar schon von alleine jetzt
bin ich draufgekommen da wie sie selber
zerdrückt aber ich schon als einfach
hier weg das vordere kann ja noch
benutzen
der erste geburtstag ist schon was
besonderes wenn auch wenn sich das kind
später nicht dran erinnert aber für die
mama papa oma für später wenn man dann
wieder auf die bilder zurückblickt ist
doch was schönes
krone befestige ich hier so ein bisschen
versetzt
sternchen ich glaube ich dass es doch
weg ich bin was ich weg ich las den
zauberstab weg aber ich nehme essbare
thiermann diamanten
die nimmt er mit einer pinzette auf
ansonsten werden sie nämlich macht durch
das fett an den fingern an der haut
zu setzen und fertig ist die dortige ich
glaube so ist schön und nicht zu
überladen
[Musik]
die torte wird jetzt so wie sie ist
transportiert ich werde nur vorher die
zahl eins die diamanten und die krone
herr unternehmen damit einfach beim
transport nichts passiert die dort darf
auch in den kühlschrank die deko
elemente die kann man einfach bei
raumtemperatur lagern vor allem auch die
diamanten weil die ansonsten eben matt
werden das wäre ziemlich schade
und so wird erst übermorgen leider erst
die geburtstagsfeier gefeiert aber das
ist gar nicht schlimm
im kühlschrank hält sie sich nämlich
auch solange der boden ist super saftig
die creme hält die marmelade hält also
kann man so eine torte wirklich ganz
toll vorbereiten
ich bin so jedenfalls ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen das rezept gibt es auch
felix - blog.de und wir sehen uns wieder
beim nächsten mal tschüss und daran
denken wenn ihr euch eine jungen motiv
tolle wünsche schreibt gerne eure
vorschläge in die kommentare
denn ich bin hat auch eine mädchen man
hat zwei mädels und ich weiß immer nicht
so ganz worauf jungs stehen also
schreibt mir
[Musik]